Prof: Okay,
let's get started.
So last time we looked at
methane and ammonia,
and saw something interesting
about molecular orbitals:
we could give them the same
name as atomic orbitals;
that is, if we,
especially if we look at a low
electron density contour of the
molecular orbitals,
we see that what it looks like
is an atom where the nucleus is
split into pieces.
Right?
Now that splitting into pieces
changes the potential energy for
the electron.
So you expect that to distort
the orbital.
The electrons will move in the
directions that pieces of the
nucleus have gone.
But then, in addition to
potential energy controlling the
shape of orbitals,
kinetic energy also does.
And that's the same thing as it
is in an atom.
You have a thing with no nodes,
a thing with one node --
and when you have one node you
can have either a spherical
node,
or a planar node,
and there can be three planar
nodes;
so a 2s and three
2p's.
Exactly the same considerations
apply in a molecular orbital as
in an atomic orbital.
You have the kinetic energy,
which comes with curvature,
which comes with nodes.
Now, as you split the nucleus
up and pull pieces in different
directions,
it doesn't have the same
symmetry it had when it was all
together in the nucleus,
a spherical kind of symmetry.
So the nodes get distorted.
But still you can see them
there.
And we saw them last time and
went through all the occupied
and vacant valance orbitals of
ammonia and methane,
and saw how they looked like
atomic orbitals.
This, not surprisingly,
because it's so fundamental,
the potential energy and the
kinetic energy,
applies to every system.
It applies to you,
viewed as a single atom --
right?
-- with a zillion electrons.
Okay?
But pieces have moved around,
so the orbitals change.
We'll look at two more
complicated cases and then we'll
get on to a different way of
looking at bonding.
So we'll look at ethane and
methanol.
And we use -- I didn't tell you
last time, explicitly,
where I got the molecular
orbitals from.
I got them from my laptop.
There's a program -- the
particular one is called
Spartan,
that I use -- and it calculates
what molecular orbitals look
like,
using approximate molecular
orbital (that is,
Schrödinger equation kind
of) theory.
Okay, so let's just look at the
ones of ethane and methanol.
Now both of these have seven
pairs of valence electrons.
There are also core electrons,
and if we were looking at the
orbitals for all the electrons,
we'd include those.
And exactly how we're going to
count those --
you could do it one way or the
other --
whether you consider the core
electrons,
the 1s electrons to just
be part of the nucleus and then
treat the rest as the electrons
you're interested in;
or whether you want to count
the core electrons too.
You can do it either way,
but what you analogize to what
depends on whether you count
them as part of the nuclei.
So anyhow, we're going to
compare these molecular orbitals
to the atomic orbitals of argon,
which has also seven electron
pairs.
Okay, so there's the 2s
orbital.
I'm going to start with that,
because I'm going to pretend
that that red part is the core
-- that there's a 1s
which is core electrons.
But in this case -- here's my
pedantic note on this
subject which I just added.
So if you have -- before we had
just one heavy atom,
carbon in methane,
nitrogen in ammonia.
Right?
So there was one 1s
orbital.
Right?
Now we have two heavy atoms,
carbon and carbon in methane,
carbon and oxygen in methanol.
So there are two heavy atoms
and therefore two boring core
orbitals.
So for purposes of making
analogies,
we'll use the atomic 1s
orbital,
of the atom that we're
analogizing things to,
to stand for all the molecular
core orbitals.
You can do it any way you want
to.
We're not really interested in
that.
We're interested in the valence
orbitals.
So whether I start with the
1s or the 2s
depends on how I'm handling the
core electrons;
it's not a big deal.
Anyhow, let's pretend it's the
2s of argon here,
and we're going to compare it
with this lowest valence level
molecular orbital of ethane.
Now we can -- as I do this,
on the left side of the
pictures I'm going to show one
view,
and then, because it's more
complicated than methane and
ammonia were,
I'm going to also show a
picture rotated by ninety
degrees.
So I'm going to rotate around
that axis, and on the right I'll
show a different view of the
same orbital.
Okay, so that's the lowest
valence level molecular orbital
of ethane.
And it's not very exciting;
it's just a distorted sphere.
And you can see the way in
which it's distorted.
It's distorted vertically,
because the two carbons are
pulled apart;
so it's got sort of a narrow
waist to it.
And then it's pulled out,
where each of the protons left
the middle atom to come out and
be hydrogens.
Okay?
Now if we look at methanol,
it'll be a little different.
Can you anticipate how it might
be different if,
on the bottom we'll have CH_3
again, but on the top,
instead of having CH_3,
we're going to have OH.
How do you think it might be
different, in the way it looks?
Student:  It might be
skewed more towards the OH
because oxygen is --
Prof: Okay,
so oxygen has a bigger nuclear
charge.
So that's going to pull the
lowest energy orbital toward the
oxygen.
That'll be one thing.
We expect it to be bigger,
top-heavy.
Okay?
What else, about how the top
will look?
How will it be different from
if it were a CH_3?
Yes, Alex?
I can't hear very well.
Student:  Oxygen has
lone pairs.
Prof: Oxygen has lone
pairs.
Now, how is that going to
change things?
Or another way of saying the
same thing is it has only one
hydrogen up there.
How's that going to change it,
do you think?
You have to speak up.
Student:  It's not going
to be symmetrical.
Prof: It's not going to
be symmetrical.
Which way is it going to be
distorted to be unsymmetrical?
You have to speak up.
Student:  Towards the
electron pair.
Prof: Toward the
electron pair did you say?
I couldn't hear.
Student:  Away from
hydrogen.
Prof: Away from hydrogen?
Well how about -- the proton
goes out;
does it bring electrons with
it, or does it repel electrons,
the proton?
Speak up.
Student:  It brings them.
Prof: It pulls,
so it should distort toward the
hydrogen.
So here's what it looks like.
Right?
It's top-heavy,
as Angela said,
and it's distorted out toward
the hydrogen;
there are no protons pulling it
to the top left.
And you see the same thing
end-on there,
on the right.
Okay, this is the next orbital.
What does that look like?
Obviously you can peek in the
middle and see.
It's obviously a 2p_z
orbital, with the node across
the middle.
Okay?
In both cases.
Now the ethane case is
symmetrical.
The other case is unsymmetrical.
Why is it unsymmetrical?
Because the first orbital
pulled electrons to the top.
Right?
So the next- in the next
orbital, electrons aren't going
to want to be at the top so
much,
because they're going to be
repelled by the other electrons;
so there'll be more toward the
bottom, because the first ones
went to the top.
Okay?
Okay, then here's the next
orbital.
You can see there are energies
marching up here.
The lowest one was s,
then 2p_z,
now 2p_x,
if we define the horizontal
axis here on the left as the x
axis.
So again, it's what you expect,
and it's pulled out,
stretched vertically from being
a dumbbell by where the nuclei
went.
And here's 2p_y,
which we can see more clearly
on the right,
perpendicular to the
2p_x.
Okay?
And notice that it's obviously
so, that the methanol orbital
will be less symmetric,
in all cases,
than the one for ethane.
But still we can recognize the
nodes, because they must go that
way.
It must be no nodes,
one node of three different
kinds, and so on.
Okay, now this is 3s.
You notice it has -- the node
that we don't see,
the one that's down near the
nuclei,
in fact two nodes down near the
one for each of the heavy atoms.
But then this now has another
spherical node,
or approximately spherical
node.
So we have that extra red lump
in the middle on the top,
or blue, in the middle.
Just to review,
what's the difference between
red and blue?
On the top, the computer
decided to draw it with red in
the middle.
On the bottom it decided to
draw it with blue in the middle.
What do those colors mean?
Yes, Cathy?
Student:  Positive and
negative signs.
Prof: The mean positive
and negative.
So which one is right?
Should it be positive in the
middle or negative in the
middle?
Student:  Positive.
Prof: Positive is a
guess.
Wilson, what do you say?
Student:  It doesn't
matter.
Prof: Why not?
Student:  Because it's
not really positive or negative;
it's just kind of a phase of it.
Prof: Yes,
it's the sign of the wave
function.
But you can multiply the wave
function by minus one,
any constant,
and it's just as good as it was
before.
So it's arbitrary,
and the computer was arbitrary
in choosing the colors.
I think there's actually a
function that I could've changed
it, if I'd thought to do so,
so they'd be the same.
But actually it tells a story
if I leave them different.
Okay, so here's the next one.
Now this is -- if you look on
the left now,
it's more clear where the nodes
are, that that's a d_xz
orbital.
The name 'xz' means that
the product of x and z appears
in the wave function.
Right?
So when both x and z are
positive, then the product is
positive;
on the top right, red. Right?
When x is negative,
and z is positive,
the top left,
it's negative,
the product of them.
So that's why it has the name
xz.
Okay, and there's d_yz,
which you see on the right,
turned ninety degrees.
And here's the d_z^2,
which is that thing that has a
doughnut that goes around the
middle.
Right?
It's hard to see the doughnut.
Can you see?
It's blue on top.
You can easily see the red on
the top left,
which is what's blue in the
middle;
the sign has changed. Right?
But the doughnut is highly
distorted,
because as you go around,
first a proton on the top pulls
it up,
then a proton on the bottom
pulls it down,
then up, down.
So it's like a crown,
the doughnut has been made into
a crown around the end,
by the protons pulling in that
way.
Okay.
Then here's the 3p_z.
So it has the horizontal nodal
plane, but also it has a
spherical node,
which you can see in either
picture really.
Okay?
Then here's the 3p _y
orbital,
which again has that spherical
node,
but now the planar node,
or approximately planar node,
is vertical instead of
horizontal.
So say on the top right there
you have red on the right and
blue on the left.
There's a vertical node over
which it changes sign,
going right to left.
Or here's the 3_px.
Or here's the 3d_xy;
which you don't see so well
here;
well, but if you turned it down
you would.
And here's the
3d_x^2-y^2;
which again,
to see it well,
you'd have to turn it.
And here's the 4f
orbital.
So you can see,
especially say in the top ones,
compared with the atomic
orbital, that it's exactly the
same general pattern of nodes,
slightly distorted.
And incidentally,
remember all the n
equals whatever,
n=3;
all the orbitals had the same
energy before.
Now they don't have all the
same energy.
Notice that they all have
different energies.
None of them are degenerate.
Why?
Because if you broke the
nucleus apart,
how stable a thing that has
that general shape,
like a dumbbell or a cloverleaf
or something,
how stable the electrons are in
those lumps depends on whether a
proton got pulled into the lump.
If there happens to be a proton
in the lump, where kinetic
energy, the node pattern,
wants it to be,
then that'll be unusually
stable.
If the protons have been pulled
someplace where there is a node,
because of kinetic energy,
then it won't be stabilized.
So that breaks the degeneracy
of these different patterns that
have the same number of nodes.
It depends on where the -- how
the potential energy changed.
Okay, now just finally and very
quickly,
I want to look at
1-flouoroethanol,
which is a molecule that would
have,
I think, no stability at all,
but you can put it into the --
as a practical matter,
you're never going to put it in
a bottle,
but you can easily put it into
the computer and calculate what
its molecular orbitals would
look like.
And I did it to show you
something that's very,
very unsymmetrical,
and has atoms of very different
nuclear charge.
Okay?
So what will the very,
very, very lowest orbital look
like, do you think,
for this thing?
It has a fluorine,
an oxygen, two carbons and five
hydrogens.
So what do you think?
If you were an electron,
and you had that set of nuclei,
arranged this way,
where would you want to go?
Elizabeth?
Student:  Very biased to
the left, especially around the
fluorine.
Prof: Yes.
Now what would the very,
very, very lowest one?
It should be more toward the
left, and really close to the
fluorine.
It would be a 1s
orbital, and mostly on fluorine,
because that's where most of
the protons are,
the most concentrated protons.
So let's look.
There's a smaller scale ball
model,
so that we can see really small
orbitals,
and there that's,
you're absolutely right,
it's essentially the 1s
orbital of fluorine,
is the very lowest orbital.
What would be next?
Suppose this one,
you came up and this seat was
already taken,
now where would you go,
the next electron?
Zack?
Student:  Oxygen.
Prof: To the oxygen,
because that's the next highest
concentration of protons.
And next?
Where will you go next?
Steve, what do you say?
The 1s of fluorine is
taken.
The 1s of oxygen is
Where do we want to go next?
Pardon me?
Student:  One of the
carbons.
Prof: Ah, which carbon?
Student:  The left
carbon.
Prof: Why?
Student:  Because it's
closer to the fluorine than the
oxygen.
Prof: And what does the
proximity have to do with it?
The proximity means that the
electrons that are on that atom
will have been drawn toward --
and we'll talk about this more
later --
will have been drawn toward the
fluorine and the oxygen.
Therefore that atom will have
fewer electrons,
or lower electron density.
Right?
Therefore, it's a better place
for other electrons to go.
Okay?
So you'd expect the next one to
be the middle carbon.
Right!
And finally,
of course, it's going to be the
second carbon,
the one that's remote from the
electronegative,
high nuclear charge atoms.
Okay, now we've done all the
1s's.
So we can look at what's
interesting, the valence
orbitals, the ones that are
going to be involved in bonding;
these don't have anything to do
with bonding.
Okay, so there's the first one.
Russell, tell me something
about the shape of this?
Does it surprise you?
Student:  No.
It's highly distorted towards
the fluorine.
Prof: Yes,
it has no nodes;
except it actually has little
nodes down near the nucleus,
because it's actually more like
a 2s orbital in that
respect,
because of the core electrons.
So it has tiny nodes that we
don't see around the nuclei.
But it has no nodes within the
valence;
big orbitals that we're looking
at.
So it's like an s
orbital.
Right?
And it's big where the nuclear
charge is big,
as you say.
Okay?
What's the next one going to
look like?
Any ideas?
Pardon me?
Student:  Towards the
oxygen.
Prof: Toward the oxygen.
Will it also have no nodes?
No.
The next highest orbital has to
have a node.
Where do you think the node
will be?
What orbital will it look like,
sort of?
It'll be highly distorted.
But what -- if this is the s
orbital, right?
What's going to be next?
Elizabeth?
Student:  It's as if
it's switched but with a planar
node in between.
Prof: Oh let's see.
Right!
So the first one was -- you
were right Russell that this one
should be big on oxygen.
But notice it's like a p
orbital, it has that horizontal
node, because it's higher
kinetic energy.
Okay?
And then this one,
that's on the carbons,
right?
Mostly.
But it's a p_y,
it has a vertical node.
So it's negative say on the
fluorine and oxygen and positive
on the carbons.
Or if we rotate this one around
a horizontal axis to look at it
from the side,
it looks like that,
and you can see that it's a
p_y kind of orbital.
Elizabeth?
Student:  I'm just
asking a point of clarification.
These aren't technically
p orbitals,
right?
We're just saying they're
analogous to them.
Prof: They're analogous
to p orbitals;
because it has to be the same.
The orbitals must go in order
of the number of nodes.
Right?
So the same thing is in an atom
or in a molecule.
You go from no nodes to one
node.
And there are three ways of
getting one node:
spherical or distorted sphere,
planes, or distorted planes if
the nuclei are pulled around;
and so on.
So they're really very much
like the atomic orbitals.
Okay, or this one.
Now that's an interesting one
because that's like a hybrid
orbital.
It looks like the orbital up
here.
It's a mixture of s with
p.
Did everybody see how that is?
It's a big sort of blue lobe on
the top and a small red one on
the bottom.
And also the next one is the
other one,
the hybrid that points the
other direction,
another combination of the
s and the p,
that points down.
Okay?
And then this one looks like
d_xy again.
Right?
It's sort of a cloverleaf with
two nodes.
Okay, so that's all I want to
do with that,
and we won't go any further
with it.
This is just an interesting way
of looking at how --
that molecular orbitals are
really just like atomic
orbitals,
and have energies for the same
reason,
except the potential energy
gets screwed up by breaking the
nucleus and pulling pieces
around,
but in an understandable way,
and the nodes get distorted
because of this.
Okay now, now we're getting
into really -- we just looked at
this view, at the single united
atom view.
But the other view is the one
that's going to be more
generalizable,
and that's the one where we
looked at bonding.
Right?
So you have to probe a little
harder to get a qualitative
understanding of what chemical
bonds are.
And that's what we're going to
do now by choosing a higher
contour with which to look at a
molecule.
Now, true molecular orbitals,
to the extent that orbitals are
true all together -- why aren't
they true all together;
why aren't orbitals true all
together?
Yes, Alex?
Student:  Because you
have multiple electrons.
Prof: Because you have
many electrons;
you can't have independent
electrons, you can't have
orbitals.
But we're approximating things
by orbitals,
trying to take electron
interaction into account in a
sort of a left-handed way by
Self-Consistent Field,
or something like that.
Because it's much easier if we
can divide the whole into a
bunch of parts,
each of which we can
understand.
So, to the extent that
molecular orbitals are true --
the kinds of things I've just
been showing you,
calculated with my laptop --
they extend over the whole
molecule;
they're not local. Right?
Except like the 1s of
fluorine was local,
but mostly they go over the
whole molecule.
But bonds are thought of,
and have always been thought
of, as interactions between
pairs of atoms.
So we want to divide things
completely differently and look
at the bonds now,
at pairwise LCAO molecular
orbitals.
Now what's an LCAO?
It's a sum, or a linear
combination.
Right?
A weighted sum of atomic
orbitals.
So here's an example.
Î¨, which is an orbital --
what's it a function of?
Student:  Position.
Prof: Position of what?
Student:  One electron.
Prof: One electron.
So it's a function of
x_1,y_1,z_1;
we're talking just about
electron one.
So the wave function for
electron one we say is
1/âˆš2 times one
atomic orbital plus another
atomic orbital.
Right?
Now, have you ever seen adding
orbitals like that before?
That's what hybridization is;
we added s and p.
But this is different,
because when we added s
and p before,
they were on the same nucleus,
and we did it to get a new
orbital for that particular
nucleus for that atom;
to distort it one way or the
other, for example,
or to rotate a p
orbital.
Right?
But this is very different,
because we're adding orbitals
that are on different
nuclei: A, nucleus A,
and nucleus B.
See the difference?
Adding is just -- wave
functions are numbers,
we just add the numbers.
But in the first case,
hybridization,
those two functions were on the
same nucleus.
Now they're on different
nuclei, what we're adding
together.
Okay, now why is it sensible to
think that you might get
pairwise molecular orbitals that
can be expressed like this?
How do you interpret an orbital?
Corey?
What good is an orbital?
What do you use it for?
Student:  It's a
one-electron wave function.
Prof: Well what do you
use it for?
Student:  For
probability.
Prof: And how do you get
probability?
From the wave function -- if
you have the wave function,
how do you get the probability
density?
Student:  You square it.
Prof: You square it.
So do you see why we have a
1/âˆš2 in this?
Because when we square it,
that's going to be half,
and we're going to get half of
atomic orbital A squared,
and of atomic orbital B
squared;
so it's a half of each of them.
That's why we have
1/âˆš2.
So let's go on with this.
Suppose we have a hydrogen
molecule, and suppose that the
nuclei are at a great distance
from one another.
So far they don't interact,
or negligible interaction;
they're very far apart.
What would you expect the
lowest energy,
one-electron wave function to
look like?
One possibility is that the
electron could sit exactly
halfway between the two nuclei?
Right?
Is that a reasonable place,
is that the low energy place
for it to be?
Lucas, what do you say?
Student:  No,
because the added probability
density there is not the
greatest.
Prof: Why not?
Student:  It needs to be
one or the other.
Prof: Why shouldn't the
electrons sit -- if the two
nuclei are this far apart;
and I don't mean two angstroms
apart, I mean two meters apart
-- there's a proton here and a
proton here.
Is the electron most likely to
be here, halfway between?
Student:  No.
Prof: Where would it be
most likely?
Student:  Probably
nearer to one of the two atoms.
Prof: And which of the
two?
<<Students speak over one
another>>
Prof: Suppose you took
the long view.
Suppose you averaged it over
eighteen zillion millennia --
time averaged.
Sometimes it would be near this
one, sometimes it would be near
this one.
Okay?
What would it be if you took a
really long view?
Student:  Both.
Prof: And half here,
and half here.
So the wave function,
when you square it,
you want it to be half looking
like this atom,
and half looking like this
atom.
Then you see the time average.
Right?
It might take a long time to
achieve that average,
because it'd take a long time
for the electron to tunnel two
meters, right?
But in the very,
very long time it would look
like that.
So we know what we want it to
look like.
What we want is that the
probability density,
the square of this one-electron
wave function,
should look half of the time
like the atomic orbital A
squared and half of the time
like atomic orbital B squared.
So on time average it's half of
one and half of the other.
Everybody with me?
So that's what the -- yes, Nate?
Student:  Why isn't
there a 2A -- or a 2AB?
Prof: Oh,
because I'm telling you what it
looks like.
It's got to look half like this
and half like this.
Right?
So the square of it has to be
this.
So all we have to do to find
the wave function is what,
if we know what its square is?
All we got to do is take the
square root and we've got the
wave function.
Bingo!
There's the square root. Right?
So that is a reasonable way to
write the wave function,
1/âˆš2 (AO_A +
AO_B). Claire,
you have a question.
Student:  From my small
understanding,
with the math that I've got --
and this may be wrong,
correct me if I'm wrong.
But don't you,
if you have a bracket and two
things inside it,
you square outside of it,
don't you have four things that
come out of it.
Prof: You want that?
Student:  Yes.
>
Prof: Okay,
now Claire you're going to help
me out.
How big is -- that's a number.
It's the product of -- atomic
orbital A assigns numbers
everywhere in space,
everywhere in space.
Atomic orbital B assigns
numbers everywhere in space.
So at some point in space
atomic orbital B assigns a
number and atomic orbital A
assigns a number;
and A times B is the product of
those two numbers.
How big is that product?
How big is atomic orbital A
here?
This, a meter away from the
proton?
Student:  Not very big.
Prof: And how big is
atomic orbital B there?
Student:  Not very big.
Prof: Now how big is
atomic orbital A here?
Student:  Very big.
Prof: Okay.
So now, how big an error do we
make if we neglect A times B?
Where do we make an error?
Do we make an error here?
Student:  No.
Prof: Do we make an
error here?
Student:  No.
Prof: Do we make an
error here?
Student:  Yes.
Prof: No!
We make an error;
yes, sure enough,
we make an error.
How big is the error?
Student:  Not very big.
Prof: Ah,
it's negligible,
because it's at great distance.
Okay, so at great distance we
can forget that.
So now it's easier to take the
square root, right?
Okay?
The old fox up here, huh?
>
Okay, now your problem
is what happens if H_2 is at the
bonding distance?
What if they're only an
Angstrom apart?
Now there should be a problem,
because A times B is not going
to be negligible everywhere now.
Okay, so now that's going to
come back.
So now we got an error, right?
Or do we?
Let's think what that does.
Okay, so we if approximate the
molecular orbital as the sum of
atomic orbitals,
this way, then it looks very
good near the nuclei.
Because near A it looks like A;
near B it looks like B.
And if we want to square it to
find the electron density,
we do this.
But if we then subtract,
what the atoms would give for
electron density.
Now what does this remind you
of, where we look at the total
electron density and subtract
the atoms?
Student:  Difference
density.
Prof: So we're actually
looking for the difference
density.
Everybody with me on this?
So we're going to subtract the
atoms, which is ½A^2 and
½B^2.
Right?
If we subtract, what do we get?
What do we get for a difference
density?
We get A times B.
So we get the difference
electron density,
which is due to overlap.
And what do I mean by overlap?
I mean that is only important
in regions where both of them
have a finite value.
Right?
The product of A and B is
negligible if A is zero;
it's negligible if B is very,
very small.
Right?
So it's only where they
overlap, the two functions have
simultaneous values,
that you care.
Okay, now that thing,
the thing that's the bonding,
the difference density,
is really a byproduct --
that's a little bit of a pun
because it's a product --
but it's a byproduct of
squaring the sum --
of what Claire didn't like
about it.
So the very thing you didn't
like is what's going to give
rise to bonding density.
Isn't that neat?
Okay, but notice that here
we're multiplying A times B.
But this is a completely
different instance of
multiplying from what we had
before.
Right?
Before we multiplied two
orbitals to try to get a
two-electron wave function.
This has nothing to do with
this, because both of these are
functions of the same electron;
it's like one electron that
we're squaring here.
So this A times B,
this product,
this overlap,
comes from the squaring.
It was when we squared it that
we got that.
Okay?
Now, because we have this extra
term,
we have not only
½(A^2+B^2),
which would -- what's the
probability of A^2^( )summed
over all space,
or integrated,
if it's normalized?
Students:  One.
Prof: And this one?
Prof: And what's this
whole quantity?
Students:  One.
Prof: One,
because of the half.
But actually we've got it
bigger than that,
because we added the overlap
term to it.
Right?
So it's actually not going to
be half;
it'll have to be something a
little less than half,
so that it'll sum up to one,
if we want to normalize it.
Okay?
So there's going to be those
less than halves there.
Okay.
Now what does that do?
That shifts electron density,
right?
We're taking electron density
away from where the nuclei are,
from A^2 and B^2,
and where's the electron
density going?
Because we're using less than
half to begin with,
we're taking electron density
away.
There's going to be -- we're
subtracting more than was there
at the beginning.
Right?
Which means that we're going to
have negative electron density
in the difference map.
Electrons are going away from
the atoms.
Where are they going to?
Student:  Into it.
Prof: Into the region
where there's overlap.
Right?
So they go away from there,
into the overlap region.
So this is just like what we
were seeing with X-ray.
Okay, so that overlap,
the A times B term,
is what creates bonding.
And we've seen this before.
Remember when you have wells
far apart, the wave function is
the sum of the two;
we saw this in one-dimension.
Right?
But if they come close
together, you get a wave
function that looks like that,
which we looked before,
just from the point of view of
the energy,
and saw that that would
stabilize the particle,
because it's got less
curvature, less kinetic energy.
Right?
But also the electron density
grows in the middle.
Right?
So from the point of view of
the electron distribution,
that was the glue holding the
atoms together.
So it's held together,
both because the energy goes
down and because you put this
glue in the middle,
which is what causes the energy
to go down.
Okay?
So that's bonding.
And remember we also had this.
So as the energy went up in the
middle one, the energy is lower
here than it was in the atoms
apart.
So the nuclei push one another
apart now, without the glue in
the middle, and that was
anti-bonding.
So we've seen it before in
one-dimension,
but it's true in
three-dimensions as well.
Now let's think about this
again.
So here's atom A.
Now where is the square of that
function significant?
Is it significant there?
No.
Yes, it's a little bit
significant at least.
How about there?
A little bit. Right?
Okay.
Now suppose we have another
atomic orbital there.
Now, where is the product
significant, of A times B?
Okay?
So is the product A times B
significant there?
No.
Is it significant there?
Nick, what do you say?
Student:  No.
Prof: Why not?
Speak up.
Student:  It's very
small near A.
Prof: What's very small?
Student:  The value of A.
Prof: No,
no.
The value of A there is
something -- we said that
before, when we were looking
only at A -- it's not very big
but there's a significant value.
But how about the product?
Josh?
Student:  The value of B
is very small.
Prof: The value of B is
very small there.
So the product is going to be
very small.
How about there?
Student: There's going
to be a change.
Prof: Ah,
now they're equal;
halfway between they're equal.
So both of them are a little
bit small, but their product is
still significant.
Right?
Only in this region,
where they overlap,
is that product significant.
Okay.
So at the center,
notice that the number
Î¨_A assigns and the
number Î¨_B assigns
are the same number.
So 2(Î¨_A Î¨_B) is
as large as
(Î¨_A)^2+(Î¨_B)^2;
because Î¨_A times
Î¨_B is the same as
(Î¨_A)^2.
So the electron density is
nearly doubled in the middle
from what it would've been if it
had just been two atoms.
So that's the region of
significant overlap,
and that's what we care about.
So the overlap integral,
summing this produc -- or
integrating it -- over all that
space, that's a certain density.
Right?
We squared in order to get
that.
Right?
That's part of the density.
So we sum that,
the density that comes from
that product,
over all space,
and that's called the overlap
integral.
If the atoms are very far
apart, the overlap integral is
essentially zero.
If the atoms are close
together, the overlap orbital
will be finite,
and the better the -- the more
the orbitals overlap,
the bigger the overlap
integral, obviously.
And that measures the net
change that arises on bonding,
the difference density,
as we've just seen.
Now let's look at some
theoretical examples here.
So let's look at the total
electron density as calculated
for two -- adding two 1s
orbitals of hydrogen at the
appropriate distance for H_2.
This was this was done forty
years ago and published in the
Israel Journal of
Chemistry.
Okay now, and here's -- so on
the left we have the total
electron density that you'd
calculate from that.
A very simple thing:
1/âˆš2(A+B).
And you square it,
and you get the density,
and that's the density,
contoured at 0.025
electrons/cubic a_o,
the unit of distance.
Okay, now, on the right is the
difference density.
So from that thing on the left
we've subtracted the atomic
orbital, the atomic electron
densities.
And you see exactly what you
expect.
It builds up in the middle,
where there's overlap,
and at the expense of the
atoms.
Yes Russell?
Student:  Shouldn't it
be H_2^+ ion?
Prof: Oh,
I think it's the H_2_
molecule,
I'm sure it's the H_2_.
They aren't so
fantastically different,
because the two electrons are
in the same orbital;
two electrons can be in the
same orbital.
So one'll be twice as big as
the other.
Qualitatively they'll look very
similar.
And I think this is the H_2
molecule;
but it might be the ion,
I'm not sure.
Okay, at any rate the contours
on the right are much smaller.
Remember, difference density is
much smaller than total density.
So what you see is that it's
contoured at 0.004.
So you have one,
two, three, four,
five contours.
So you get up,
in the middle,
to 0.02 electrons per cubic
angstrom .
That's how much bonding has
changed things,
at the maximum.
Okay, now the energy that's
calculated,
with this very,
very, very crude wave function,
just one half --
1/âˆš2 times the sum
of the two atomic orbitals.
The energy, you calculate that,
is 92.9% of the true energy.
That's pretty darn good, right?
But almost all of that energy
that you calculate was already
present in the separate atoms.
We're not interested in the
energy of the separate atoms,
we're interested in how much it
changes when you make a bond,
which is a small difference
between large numbers.
So it turns out that although
we're within 7% of the true
total energy,
this simple model only
calculates about 50% of the
change in energy that came from
putting them together -- right?
-- which is much smaller.
Okay, so high accuracy is
required to calculate a correct
value of the bond energy.
This simple thing won't do it.
Well it's in the right
direction, you're halfway there,
so it's a pretty good start.
Right?
But to do the difference,
as in the same way you needed
high precision to do X-ray
difference maps,
you need better orbitals than
this,
if you want to calculate good
bond energies.
So you need to make the
orbitals better.
Okay?
Now -- so but already we can
take heart that the very crudest
model shows most,
52%, of the energy of the bond,
and it shows the electron
density building up by 0.02
electrons per cubic bohr radius.
And what we saw qualitatively
was there was a shift from the
atom to the bond,
of electron density.
Okay, now we can adjust the
molecular orbital to get a
better approximation of the true
thing.
How will we know when we've
adjusted it and it's gotten
better?
If we adjust it and get a
lower, calculate a lower average
energy --
I should've said a lower
average energy,
because if we don't have a true
wave function we get different
values for the total energy;
the kinetic won't exactly
offset the potential as you move
from place to place.
But if you get the lowest
average energy,
then that is,
by definition almost,
more realistic,
because you can easily prove
that the true energy is the
lowest possible energy;
that makes a certain amount of
sense.
The lowest possible calculated
energy is the true energy.
So if you change your wave
function and get a lower average
energy, you're closer to the
truth.
Okay?
That's called the Variational
Principle.
Okay, so here we've changed the
form of the molecular orbital.
And how did we change it?
What does a 1s orbital
look like?
Kate, do you remember the form
for a 1s atomic orbital?
I can't hear.
Student:  A sphere.
Prof: Angularly it's a
sphere.
How does it change as you go
out, do you remember?
How does it depend on
Ï ?
The same way they all depend on
Ï .
Anybody remember?
Prof: e^-Ï .
So it falls off exponentially
at a certain rate.
And that rate,
how fast it falls off,
is determined by the nuclear
charge.
Okay?
Now one way to change that
shape would be change how fast
it falls off.
Right?
It wouldn't be correct for the
atom anymore.
We've already got the correct
solution for the atom.
But we could change the shape
of the thing by changing how
fast that exponent falls off.
And we could vary that,
in the molecule,
using one half --
1/âˆš2(A+B).
But those A+B are no
longer true atomic functions,
they're a little fatter,
a little skinnier.
Okay?
And we can change how fat or
skinny it is,
until we get the lowest
molecular energy.
See, that's a way you can vary
it and find the best value.
And that's what was done here
to optimize the exponent.
And now you get a total
electron density that looks
essentially the same as it did
before.
And if you look at the
difference density,
how has it changed,
if you do this?
First, notice that the energy
got lower.
We're now to 73% of the
lowering of the bond energy.
So the total energy's gotten
lower, it's better.
And how has the electron
density changed?
It got higher in the middle.
Because what we did was spread
the exponent out a little bit,
so you had more overlap in the
middle.
Okay?
So this wouldn't have been good
for the single atom,
to spread it out,
but it gives a better function
for the molecule.
And it's still very,
very simple.
And what you see it did is it
increases the bonding density
and the bonding strength.
You get a larger shift from the
atoms to the bond.
Now, how else could you change
the shape of the atomic orbital
in order to increase the
overlap;
some way other than making a
single exponential and having it
get fatter or thinner?
Can you think of some other way?
Here you have an atomic
orbital, a sphere,
and you want to change its
shape so that it overlaps better
over here.
Right?
How could you change the shape
of an atomic orbital,
without doing really gross
damage to it,
making it a cube or something
like that, or a line?
How could you change it so it
looked pretty much still like an
atom did, has a lot of the
virtues of the atom,
but is shifted over here?
Sam?
I can't hear.
Student:  Can't you just
allow the electrons to shift?
Prof: Yes,
how am I going to write a
function that allows the
electrons to shift in the
direction I want them to?
Lexy?
Student:  You could
hybridize it.
Prof: Hybridize it!
We could hybridize to shift the
electrons.
So that's the next one.
So here we're going to --
instead of this we're going to
hybridize it.
Now, this particular
calculation did the
hybridization and also did a
little self-consistent field
calculation.
And the hybridization left it
96.7% 1s.
So essentially it's still a
normal 1s orbital.
But they added .6% of
2s, which expanded it a
little bit, because 2s is
-- goes further out than
1s.
And they added 2.7% of
2p.
Now why was 2p much more
helpful than 2s?
Lucas?
Student:  It has those
lobes.
Prof: Yes,
so it takes density from one
side and shifts it to the other.
In fact, this is precisely what
we saw before.
Notice what it did was -- how
much it increased the density in
the middle.
And notice now,
it's not taking electron
density away from the nuclei,
which was a good place for
electrons to be.
Where does it take it away from?
Student: The left one.
Prof: Out beyond the
nuclei, and shift it to the
middle.
So even before,
when it was an atom --
here's the nucleus,
a certain distance out here,
and a certain distance out
here, were the same in energy,
for that atom.
Now we've taken it from a place
which is -- out here,
and put it here.
Right?
Great idea.
Well done Lexy.
So there's what it looked like.
Remember, if it's 100 percent
at 1s,
it looks like that,
and if you change it to be
hybridized that way,
with Atom-in-a-Box,
it looks like this.
Right?
It's not much shift,
but it shifts from the left to
the right, and gives better
overlap.
Okay, but it requires the atom
to be a little bit less happy as
an atom, because it's partly
2s and 2p now.
The electrons are further from
the nucleus, but you make up for
that by having a better bond.
Okay, now notice that didn't
change the energy very much.
It went from 73% to 76%. Right?
We were already about the right
energy, but it changed the
density a lot,
to be what we want it to be.
Okay, so there's a much bigger
shift, and it's now from beyond
the nucleus into the bond.
Right?
And now we're going to do the
last thing.
We've done SCF already,
but now you have to do a higher
level calculation that'll do
correlation, take the
correlation of the electrons
into account.
And if you add some correlation
calculation to this,
you now get 90% of the bond.
If you did complete
correlation, you'd get 100% of
the bond.
What does it mean to do a
calculation with complete
correlation?
It means you don't have an
error anymore,
you've used a really good
calculation.
So already at this level,
that was done fifty years ago
almost, you get 90% of the bond.
And the bond density notice,
what about the electron
density?
Student:  No change.
Prof: It hasn't really
changed.
All that happened was that the
electrons kept apart from one
another, but the average density
was the same.
So already, with just that
hybridization,
we got very close to the truth
in electron distribution,
and three-quarters of the way
to the truth in how strong a
bond is.
So not a bad approximation.
So hybridization,
to give better overlap,
is a great thing.
So the density wasn't changed,
but you got a much better
energy.
And how so?
Because the electrons kept
apart from one another,
when you allow correlation.
Okay, so here's a pairwise
atomic orbital:
1/âˆš2(A+B);
and you can use hybridized
orbitals.
And the virtues are it's very
easy to formulate and to
understand.
And it looks like atoms,
especially when you get down
near the nuclei.
And you don't want that to
change because that's the main
event for electrons.
You get much more energy
forming atoms,
as we saw before,
than you do making new bonds,
once you have the atoms
already.
Okay.
It builds up electron density
between the nuclei,
through overlap,
which is the source of bonding.
It smoothes Î¨,
to lower the kinetic energy.
And then there's a pedantic
footnote here that actually
there's a thing called the
Virial Theorem,
which I'm not going to stress
you with,
but that little bit there,
it happens to be true.
But still we have the proper
understanding of what's going
on.
Hybridizing AOs provides
flexibility that gives you
better overlap.
And if you use all the H-like
Atomic Orbitals,
you have perfect flexibility,
you can make any shape you
want.
Okay, but we're going to keep
it simple,
use only 2s and
2p orbitals to hybridize,
because that'll get you most of
the way there and it's much
simpler,
rather than to try to mix
5f orbitals into it also.
Okay, so that's great.
And when we square it,
we get this,
which has the overlap part that
helps us out.
We have the atoms,
plus the bond,
which is the overlap,
that product part.
But we could've done the same
thing to get the same product,
as far as the atoms go,
if we'd used a minus sign
instead of a plus sign in
combining things;
although then we would've
changed the sign of the overlap
thing.
It would become minus.
So we would change it from
being less than to being greater
than, in order to have it be
normalized at the bottom.
Right?
And that's the anti-bond.
So we get both the bond and the
anti-bond by doing this.
And now we're going to go on,
next time, to overlap,
which we've already introduced,
and also the concept of
energy-match.
And when you put these two
together, you'll really
understand bonding.